tras más de 18 horas de debate y la
cámara de diputados de argentina aprobó
el proyecto de ley de interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo la iniciativa
pasa ahora al senado donde un proyecto
similar se hundió a fines de 2018
finalizó la reunión del consejo europeo
los líderes de los 27 estados miembros
se comprometieron a reducir en un 55%
sus emisiones contaminantes para 2030
lograron desbloquear los 1.8 billones de
euros del presupuesto 2021 2027
bloqueado por polonia y hungría y
adoptaron sanciones limitadas contra
turquía frente a las tensiones en el
mediterráneo oriental
una nueva caravana migrante salió de
honduras con rumbo a eeuu tras la
devastación causada por los huracanes
eta ello está las autoridades hondureñas
reportaron detenciones e impidieron el
paso a guatemala a quienes no llevan
prueba negativa de ccoo y 19
buen día para todos y gracias por
continuar con nosotros aquí en france 24
soy valentina torres sánchez iniciamos
este informativo en argentina con 131
votos a favor 117 en contra y 6
abstenciones y tras más de 18 horas de
debate la cámara de diputados aprobó el
proyecto de ley de acceso a la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo la
iniciativa impulsada por el presidente
alberto fernández contempla un acceso
libre a la interrupción voluntaria del
embarazo hasta la semana 14 y más allá
en casos de violación o riesgo para la
vida de la madre el proyecto ahora pasa
al senado nuestro corresponsal en buenos
aires- natalio cos hoy nos explicó qué
posibilidades tiene esta normativa de
ser aprobada pese a que en 2018 un
proyecto similar se hundió en el senado
no hay una claridad absoluta es cierto
que el senado tiene mayoría el
oficialismo y esta es una ley del
oficialismo por lo tanto viene con el
respaldo del presidente que es quien la
envió pero eso no necesariamente
significa que vaya a tener todos los
votos de hecho dentro de sectores del
oficialismo antes de que el presidente
enviará la ley había dudas sobre la
posibilidad de que en el senado donde
está realmente la clave la llave para el
cambio de la normativa puedan llegar a
tener los votos empieza a haber más
confianza con esta diferencia más grande
que hubo este año en diputados con
respecto al año 2018 donde fue muchísimo
más ajustado fueron solo cuatro votos de
diferencia y también con el trabajo que
pueda empezar a hacer ahora sobre todo
la gente del presidente del ejecutivo
sobre el senado y dentro del propio
senado más lo que estén haciendo en la
calle las personas como las que
estuvieron hoy aquí frente al congreso
para que el senado vote diferente en
2020 con respecto a lo que hizo en 2018
el debate sobre la legalización de la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
divide a la sociedad argentina pero es
clave para aquellas mujeres que tuvieron
que pasar por un aborto clandestino como
nos cuenta nuestro corresponsal natalio
co soy
hace 30 años cecilia maras y decidió
abortar cuando me enteré que usted
embarazada no tuve ningún tipo de
en embarazo había sido resultado de una
violación y como ocurre en muchos casos
por una mezcla de desconocimiento y el
estigma que acompaña al aborto recurrió
a la clandestinidad había una camilla en
el medio de un montón de libros todos
sucios
las preguntas antes de que la anestesia
tome efecto era
tremendas
me asustaron más que el aborto del sí
dónde estás alguien te vio nos recuerda
en la dirección
no cuentes a nadie que viniste acá quién
te está esperando abajo y al día
siguiente me tuve que ir a laburar me
desmayé me salí me caí del colectivo
pues no podía avisar que vivir por eso
con una hemorragia tremenda
por historias como estas que cientos de
mujeres salieron a celebrar frente al
congreso al día en que el presidente
alberto fernández envió al legislativo
un proyecto para legalizar el aborto y
evitar la clandestinidad una
clandestinidad que implica además cargas
legales y sociales aún cuando sea pocas
condenas firmes por aborto efectivamente
lo que hay son pocas condenas lo que no
significa que no haya todo un aparato y
todo un sistema puesto
a perseguir mujeres por hechos de aborto
es todo un sistema que se extiende
también en muchos casos al contexto más
cercano de la persona que recibe abortar
no me arrepiento
pero esta gente muy llegada a mis amigos
me han dicho dios te va a castigar vas a
quedar estéril tus hijas van a nacer mal
si tus hijos van a nacer mal
a los 24 años tuve a mi primer hija
estoy asustada hasta el momento que la
vi para que mujeres como sus hijas no
deban pasar por lo mismo que pasó ella
cecilia también lleva el pañuelo verde
que usan quienes quieren que cambien la
ley
ahora vamos a europa porque finalizó la
reunión del consejo europeo los jefes de
estado y de gobierno de los estados
miembros se comprometieron a reducir en
un 55% sus emisiones contaminantes para
2030 lograron desbloquear el presupuesto
de 1.8 billones de euros de 2021 2027
que había sido vetado por polonia y
hungría y adoptaron sanciones contra
turquía
más temprano nuestra corresponsal en
bruselas esther herrera nos amplió esta
información
sí pues la verdad es que la una gran
mayoría de los países europeos estaba a
favor de esta reducción del 55 por
ciento al menos de las gases
contaminantes pero aquí el hueso duro de
roer era polonia un país especialmente
muy muy dependiente del carbón de hecho
es un país que depende mucho de esta del
carbón y por lo tanto el polonio ha sido
la que ha hecho trasnochar a los colegas
europeos porque quería arrancar
realmente un compromiso de que habrá
suficientes fondos europeos para todos
los países para hacer frente a esta
transición ecológica porque sobre todo
también hay muchos puestos de trabajo en
juego por otra parte también se asegura
que el gas y también las centrales
nucleares se podrían seguir utilizando
algo muy importante para países como por
ejemplo para francia sobre la cuestión
de los presupuestos
polonia también era uno de los países
que bloqueaba el acuerdo junto con
hungría finalmente los líderes europeos
que habían aprobado que a partir de
ahora todos los fondos europeos tengan
que se puedan distribuir en los países
europeos tienen que asegurarse que
realmente van a respetar
derecho hungría y polonia han levantado
su veto porque consideraban que podrían
ser injustamente tratados los líderes
europeos han asegurado que se estudiará
de forma objetiva y además siempre
podrán acudir a la justicia europea si
hay dudas continuamos en centroamérica
una nueva caravana migrante salió de
honduras con rumbo a eeuu luego de que
los poderosos huracanes eta e idiota
azotaron al país dejando a miles de
personas sin hogar la violencia la falta
de empleo y la crisis sanitaria y la
destrucción de cientos de casas siguen
obligando a muchos a abandonarlo todo
las autoridades hondureñas reportaron
algunos detenidos y han impedido el paso
a guatemala a quienes no llevan prueba
negativa de ccoo y 19 el informe es de
andrea maya
los migrantes hondureños no esperaron el
amanecer para emprender un largo viaje
hacia eeuu con recursos limitados unos
buscan la ayuda de sus compatriotas
mientras que otros hacen pausas para
orar y no sentirse solos la intención de
ir para eeuu es que los otra hemos
perdido todo y aquí lo que queremos lo
que nosotros pedimos como emigrante
desde que el presidente de eeuu que
entró ahorita que por favor nos ayuden
nosotros aquí no podemos vivir ya
imagínense horita según nosotros vamos a
amanecer en la terminal y tocó que salir
nosotras estamos descansando orienta
pero no tocó que salir imaginé ahorita
arriesgando la horita a caminar de noche
perdimos todo con la con los huracanes
que hubieron y nos quedamos en la calle
el presidente no nos apoya
nos vamos con dolor en nuestra alma
porque dejamos nuestra familia aquí en
honduras pero yo sé qué
y llegamos
al lugar de destino que llevamos vamos a
poder salir adelante en el nombre
los obstáculos se presentaron en el
camino las autoridades hondureñas
incentivaron a los migrantes a regresar
ofreciendo transporte de vuelta mientras
que guatemala obligó a los viajeros a
presentar una prueba negativa de kobe 19
el paso del huracán eta y dos semanas
después el huracán
yota golpeó duramente noviembre la
infraestructura y los cultivos en
honduras un centenar de personas perdió
la vida
todo el sueño con llegar a eeuu donde se
preparan para la nueva administración
bajo la presidencia de joe biden el
presidente electo se ha comprometido a
seguir una política migratoria más
humana y ofrecer ayuda a centroamérica
para aliviar las presiones migratorias
el gobierno cubano iniciará el proceso
de unificación monetaria el primero de
enero de 2021 por lo que saldrá de
circulación el peso convertible conocido
como cook y el peso cubano quedará como
la única moneda oficial
la divisa tendrá una tasa única de
conversión de 24 pesos por dólar y los
ciudadanos tendrán 6 meses desde esa
fecha para cambiar sus cook en tiendas y
bancos el gobierno informó que también
se presentará una reforma salarial de
pensiones y se retirarán algunos
subsidios que están creados las
condiciones que permiten anunciar el
inicio de la tarea a partir del primero
de enero de 2021 con una tasa de cambio
única de 24 pesos cubanos por un dólar y
marruecos se convirtió en el cuarto país
árabe en anunciar la normalización de
relaciones diplomáticas con israel en
los últimos meses tras un acuerdo que
contó con la mediación de eeuu y en el
que el presidente de donald trump
reconoció la soberanía marroquí sobre el
sahara occidental'
el anuncio fue calificado de inaceptable
por el frente polisario
de independencia saharaui que pide un
referéndum de autodeterminación irán lo
calificó de traición
con sus reivindicaciones sobre el sahara
occidental oficialmente reconocidas las
autoridades marroquíes no tienen más que
elogios para sus aliados estadounidenses
un poco mes son la decisión de eeuu una
gran potencia miembro permanente del
consejo de seguridad de la onu y un
actor influyente en la escena
internacional es el esperado
reconocimiento del sahara marroquí y la
soberanía de marruecos sobre todo su
territorio incluidas las provincias del
sur del ecuador el reino ya controla una
gran parte del sahara occidental pero el
resto del territorio es administrado por
el frente polisario un movimiento
independentista sus representantes han
condenado la decisión de washington
trump ha decidido tomar una posición que
va en contra de derecho internacional
detroit er nacional es para mí esto no
es considerado nada más que un robo
internacional de la antigua colonia
española el sáhara occidental fue
anexionado por marruecos en 1975
provocando la resistencia del frente
polisario entonces apoyado por argelia
1991 entró en vigor una tregua y
naciones unidas convocó un referendo
sobre el futuro del territorio pero las
propuestas de independencia fueron
duramente rechazadas por marruecos
proponiendo conceder autonomía a la
región pero manteniéndola bajo su
control sin embargo el largo cese el
fuego se rompió el mes pasado cuando
marruecos lanzó una operación militar en
la zona de amortiguación acusando al
polisario de bloquear la carretera que
une marruecos con mauritania las
negociaciones políticas supervisadas por
la onu siguen estancadas a pesar del
anuncio de eeuu la organización no ha
cambiado su posición sobre el sahara
occidental'
de acuerdo con su resolución el
territorio está todavía en proceso de
descolonización en otras noticias un
comité de expertos asesores de la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de eeuu fda por sus siglas
en inglés recomendó aprobar el uso de
emergencia de la vacuna desarrollada por
facer y bayonne tec contra el coi 19
este paso acerca la aprobación final de
la fed ya que se espera en cualquier
momento veamos más en el informe de
álvaro cordero
fisher está a un paso de la aprobación
final para su distribución en eeuu un
comité asesor de la fd dio su visto
bueno a la dosis para un uso de
emergencia con 17 votos a favor 4 en
contra y una abstención- facer y 20 que
reciben el voto de comité asesor de la
sda para respaldar la posible primera
autorización de uso de emergencia de la
vacuna para combatir el cobe 19 en eeuu
si los funcionarios de la fed dan el
visto bueno final al producto es muy
probable que su reparto masivo por el
país comience la semana que viene
durante estos días decenas de hospitales
de la unión americana están recibiendo
los paquetes de preparación de las dosis
para agilizar el proceso una carrera
contrareloj que supondrá todo un desafío
tecnológico y logístico ya que eeuu
tiene aseguradas 25 millones de dosis y
la temperatura a la que deben ser
conservadas no debe superar los menos 70
grados centígrados en nueva york' esta
red de hospitales tiene ya listos sus
congeladores para guardar miles de dosis
al día
todo este congelador puede contener un
par de cientos de miles de dosis
esperemos que sólo lleguemos a albergar
unas miles inicialmente y tal vez unas
cinco mil en algún momento por lo tanto
para ser absolutamente eficientes no
será como llenar el congelador de casa
la vacuna elaborada por la compañía
moderna también tiene previsto recibir
el visto bueno la próxima semana algo
que ayudaría a que eeuu se acercarse más
a la inmunidad colectiva y al final de
una pandemia que ha matado a casi
300.000 personas en el país
por último la revista 'time' hizo
público su personaje del año pero este
2020 no es una sino dos personas la
publicación estadounidense escogió al
presidente electo joe biden y a su
fórmula vicepresidencial kamala harris
como los personajes más destacados de
este año según la revista su distinción
anual busca destacar a quienes más
afectaron las noticias o nuestras vidas
para bien o para mal
a ustedes gracias por acompañarnos
recuerden que pueden ampliar toda la
información en nuestra web france24
puntocom y que volveremos en breve con
más noticias aquí en france 24
[Música]